what what what what coin no why didn't
you tell me about the no it's what our
favorite twist ever that hurts so bad
but it's also like kind of brilliant
like so genius good citizens of the
reject Nation it is time once again for
a first watch this time we are diving
into Flashpoint a DC animated movie I
have never seen John has ever seen never
seen a koi have you read the comment
I've not read the comic koi are you
excited I'm very excited bro that's one
out of three one out of three and you
know Barry Allen as a concept I know him
as a person and as a concept and we're
good friends in real life we're gonna
find out how that tailors into this as
we dive into Flashpoint now I have read
the comic book myself but it's been
years and I intentionally did not reread
it because I hear they adapted it very
well very dutifully and very honorably
and this feels the right time going into
the year of the flash next year we
finally get our Flashpoint movie so this
feels like the time to do it while we're
up at Greg's wedding in snowy Colorado
also disclaimer if I seem like I'm dying
at any point it's because I am I have a
horrible ear infection that spread to my
nose and throat so if I sound off or
look off it's it's because I'm off but
if I cough it's not the Rona I'm not
just willingly putting John in the hot
seat of Doom I'm not the yellow Flash or
certain actors that play The Flash I
won't put People In Harm's Way all right
so before we get into this please do
it what do you mean good
so before we get into this please do
leave a like leave a comment let us know
what else you'd like us to watch in the
DC animated Pantheon because I read the
comics watch the movies but I have a
weak spot for animation so teach me show
me what I need to watch and if you want
to watch this as a full feature length
sync up where you line up with your own
copy head on over to the real rejects
patreon where we watch the entirety
alongside you for our full reaction the
Line to Line start to finish flash
experience let's get into it
yes
[Music]
I love how cinematic the openings always
are
running Network and and the silence I
was like
very unnerving yeah
Barry Allen
courage to change the things you can and
have the wisdom to know the difference I
was in AAA
oh
[Music]
oh
I could have saved her come on stop
doing this to yourself but was that
saying your mother had about accepting
the things you can't change
oh a Justice League already assembled
[Music]
oh oh
[Music]
well flash once again it looks like
you're the bottom and I'm the top
[Laughter]
good pun work
yeah
exhibits closed Tom
come back during business hours dang
[Music]
the old Rogues gallery
clever a cool texture none of you clowns
are smart enough to pull this off you're
quite right of course Flash
oh no I'm gonna bring this Shrine to
Your Ego down on your head along with 10
square blocks of Central City and
everyone around we didn't bring any
bombs oh but I did the legends of
Tomorrow didn't agree to this
[Laughter]
the adhesive will never completely
liquefy regardless of speed I'm counting
on that
tastes your medicine if it means
shattering your Golden Throne in history
linking your name forever to this City's
darkest hour then my life is a small
price to pay
oh here we go your lives aren't worth
much
but Flash's life is
each of you take one of the Rogues as
far from Central City as you can we'll
attempt to disarm the devices one
sufficiently isolated
ready break
I'm excited for James Gunn to give us
some good Green Lantern yeah right
[Music]
anybody can figure this out it's cyborg
yeah robot stuff
[Laughter]
[Music]
I've got a million microbes eating the
bombs wiring I was like the fish though
bro that's like your whole thing oh
this is gonna blow up a bunch of fish
that's how they catch fish you know
parts of the world just drop some
Dynamite figure it out it's great for
the ocean
Batman willing to risk himself in the
bubble
[Music]
oh smart yeah
all we are is Dust in the Wind dude
[Music]
cool
see that's how you ride Superman you
can't save
not the ones that matter to you like
your mom he's subtle he couldn't save
your mom
you okay don't worry about me bets I'm
fine nothing I can't run off
so he's great everyone's so like them
yeah I'm loving this so far cold is on
the loose already do we really have to
learn this stuff on TV doesn't anyone
call the cops anymore
Harry are you all right
mom
you're here well of course I'm here you
promised me you'll take me to dinner on
my birthday it's my birthday the end of
the world can't stop that
what
it's okay Barry it's easy for a busy
young man to forget his old mom
huh
oh but everything else has changed and I
have to find out why I think it probably
has something to do with me being gay
what what
it's okay I love it no matter what
good mom that delivers
brace yourself for a shock
I'm the Flash
oh the flash is gay
fastest man alive fights crime very
famous superhero
superhero
you mean like Batman
you know he could kick Batman's ass
though uh I'm way better thanks
oh the game is so well it's so cool
[Music]
Gun Man
[Music]
is John Wick and a cowl so cool
I love a good yo-yo based villain
[Music]
imagine if this is how Batman died buy a
yo-yo death by yo-yo
where's the Joker
see we got a five o'clock shadow I mean
angst yeah it's on the tip of my tongue
let me help you
no it wouldn't do you any good bats
no damn
render
you absolutely Batman
you should let her hit the pavement
we're trying to help all the people
while there's still a world left we need
you Pied Piper citizen Cole Shea Sandman
the Shazam kids
Emily you can't just turn your back on
this Batman now we've got a chance to
stop this war and save the world War's
over Soldier you just don't know it yet
they've painted it else rolled so
quickly like they've done such a good
job yeah it's like it's a lot of
exposition they're like yeah but it's
good because it's also like the right
kind of disconcerting yeah it is not
yeah a little Watchman flavor
what's Watchmen
no I don't need help
everything's fine now
no no it's not sorry bro very not fine
how is my little angel awesome daddy
took me off to lunch and we had chicken
wings and I told him about the amazing
God this is just like Superman Returns
[Laughter]
this guy where's weird Lex Luthor that
was James Marsden just animated yes Anna
Marston
can't catch a break even in animation
spawned of superheroes
no bomber
are you
I said who the hell are you who who owl
man Bruce Bruce Bruce is dead I watched
him die he's the one who died that night
in the alley
Bruce died
oh no oh no oh oh that's
that hurts
where the hell are you I'm at the
Rendezvous Point run James Cameron
my name is Colonel Steve Trevor the
United States Special Forces I'm here to
retrieve Lois Lane Lois Lane is a
Pulitzer prize-winning journalist who's
been embedded in Newton mascara for
three months Gathering Intel on your
Amazons for cyborg
the queen of the Amazons is a servant to
her people
oh
take him out for snooze new nothing is
beneath her oh
[Music]
except that oh oh oh oh oh nothing's
beneath her except a corpse in the
ground of her Steve Trevor yeah
in my world I'm a hero named The Flash
Bruce took me here showed me now let me
show you that I'm telling the truth my
uniform is in that ring
put it on bad Flash See
he hates you so much he'll destroy
everything to kill you but his psychosis
requires that you know he's responsible
could anyone even thong be that deranged
yup
if I were to help you what exactly would
we need just what's over there and
unbelievably bad weather
check welcome to Gotham all we have is
bad weather and angst yeah
wow
wow that's a lot of death I suggest if
you want to prevent further tragedies of
this magnet
got me
ravagers getting ravaged oh
Battle Stations let's go Joe Manganiello
he's got this
bro
Oke
[Music]
wow he's a water bender
nice
suck them up
oh
there he is Patrick Wilson doing the
work
now he just has to get naked I mean it's
inevitable it's never complete until
Patrick Wilson's naked
hey Black Manta cool yeah yeah surface
dwellers mallor not Amazon's medal is
warm they're in my way
at least I know I was right no survivors
damn
this is cold it's a dark other world
Comics are supposed to be fun I was
happier when I was watching the Red Hood
and that was violence
you know they say that lightning doesn't
strike the same place twice
they say a lot of things now why don't
we pull the switch and find out they
have debunked that lightning thing many
times
Dr Wayne
he's a medical doctor
of weather
not a meteorologist
[Music]
come on I'm here
I'm right here
oh yeah
oh
whoa
yeah I was like do those chemicals work
the same in this universe
turn the flesh into Deadpool
medium well
sir let my team take out the Atlantean
device but our top analysts say without
the Batman you have no team thank you
for everything you've done for this
country Victor but as of now you're
relieved of Duty thank you Obama thanks
Obama's America
this is what happened yeah this is the
else world we were all living in
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
steamy when the land of the waters Unite
no it's okay they deserve to be happy
after destroying the world yeah
oh
[Music]
killed Amber Heard they're moving this
so quickly I'm wondering how the live
action movie is gonna possibly tell this
story
that'll be fine I'll just get it out in
an expositional monologue
foreign
that way that's the Batman of the Joker
that hurts so bad but it's also like
kind of brilliant like so genius that's
why they have this lifelong Feud genius
and to return to Crime Alley that way
like oh
genius
I fear we could sweep clean the ocean
floor as well as the surface world I see
then we will take the witch's Island by
force they will pay for what they did to
Queen mirror
why did you say that name never to speak
her name
Queen Martha
how does he stay so bulky under the sea
is that dense he's so thick he's like 12
Seas thick because of you I'll be
responsible for the deaths of Millions
that can't be good the odds against
recreating the exact variables of the
original accident are then just try to
douse the Flames a little faster this
time okay you know they say lightning
doesn't strike Thrice
that old expression I feel good about
this tape this is masking tape
I'm getting too old for this [ __ ]
foreign
[Music]
told you I was fast
I need a drink
Amazon's captured some of Aquaman's
Advanced Scouts
Wonder Woman's lasso made them spill
their guts
literally oh
golden lasso of evisceration I wrote in
some unusual size
they remain defined
the goat yeah
let's go barreled I know Thon has the
yellow ghost Trails its reverse flash
stupid stupid
no Jeeps who are you
what are you
or when are you oh
I would have if it weren't for whichever
one of you can run at super speed I
don't know what you think just happened
but there ain't no speeds to run this
team nah it's kind of very crazy what do
you think just happened grifter you saw
it yeah
no we're taking credit for that no that
was ours don't worry about it it's just
an incidental byproduct of our greatness
great coincidence
I had to make some last minute
alterations I suggest you take it for a
test run and make sure you can break
that time barrier once we know that
we can stop Darkseid
so I'm finally on the other end of that
trip
I feel like the Batman getting Batman is
now its own in every Universe scene yeah
like my son would hate this too I get it
guys it's annoying but I'm fine
faster
higher further faster baby get him get
him get him get him maybe not in your
first run
no Barry
just gotta practice a little more this
mission is no Cakewalk in fact in fact
in all likelihood it's a one-way trip
and if I'm afraid if I want to back out
no hard feelings something like that
something like that
except you have to do it in my life I
felt like something really special was
waiting for me I think I just found it
so the last thing I am is afraid oh how
Jordan's got no fear in any Universe in
my new memories of this timeline I saw
something
a meteor it hit a City Metropolis 30
years ago the same day Superman's rocket
crashed in my reality what has podcast
been telling him to keep it on the low
and he actually listened this time yeah
you still need a strategist for your
little army yes I'll do it
but my way I kill everybody only use
guns a lot of guns he wants to stop the
war so do we that's all he needs to know
I don't hack into government systems
Batman
do now if you want me on your little
Suicide Squad
Amanda Waller where's she at in this
universe definitely if Dad if Lex got
taken like if you're hunting smart
people oh yeah which I imagine they
would have done right like tactically
I'm trusting that this is absolutely
necessary
that's why we're here
damn
it's like the thing in here
oh the S stands for hope so cool
[Music]
oh no
[Applause]
oh oh no
notice the color of the room so smart
are you okay
oh
me
healing can begin so beautiful
I have direct orders from the president
of the United States maybe I can end
this peacefully yeah maybe
over here
sweet
guns gunman
whoa
damn let's go soups
[Music]
friends
damn Superman close your eyes
God this is so twisted
[Music]
oh no no
existential crisis Superman not now
there you are baby hold still for
highball
the green torpedo beware my power
[ __ ]
in Brightest Day in [ __ ] night
oh yeah
final battle between Atlantis and the
Amazons has begun there's nothing we can
do now enjoy the things you love with
the time we have left
there's bound to be looting in Gotham by
now
[Laughter]
we'll go to London fight
s and save the world in the process what
the hell let's do this
is the Bat Plane big enough for all of
us the what the what oh no
Lois Lane was an embedded reporter
turned resistance fighter she saw
something in new them obscure oh
and I Thon if it was him why let Lane
live much less helper if he's as fast as
you why let himself be seen
cause he's a serial killer and he wants
credit yep it's like a path
[Music]
sweet
uh what chaos so much and it's cool to
have these two yeah factions warring
like Flashpoint could be a Trilogy like
there's so much yeah oh dude I mean how
cool would that be like this is like
Black Hawk Down yeah just this but with
characters you've lived with call up
James Gunn James I got an idea once we
have Aquaman or Wonder Woman this war is
over
foreign
[Music]
she tried to assassinate me Arthur I was
protecting myself yet you wear her
helmet like a trophy no a warning
you cheated man
laughs
[Music]
I can't believe I ever loved you you
never did oh
oh
[Music]
damn
oh
nope
I'm getting out of here not my fight
let's go not Deadpool yeah come on
almost Deadpool
Deadpool I think rifter is around the
same time too I think he was like a 90s
really yeah
Yeah man they need their they need yeah
a Pity we never teamed up when the world
still existed Batman and grifter the boy
idiot
oh
no no
you didn't tell me this was gonna do all
this [ __ ] to me koi
it's not a light story it's a crazy ride
might change all this
no
I won't stand by while people are
oh oh I love what you've done with the
place this is all your fault
oh no
[Music]
Ah Holy rebar Batman
so frustrating
yeah cool guys spit out blood yeah yeah
then they see what Vengeance must be
wrought
no grifter my new favorite character
oh yeah I even got Deadpool taken out
yeah I got boromired what did you do to
the war
you did how's that
you broke the time barrier flash Time
Boom ripples of distortion radiated out
through that point of impact shifting
everything just a tiny bit enough for
events to happen slightly different so
we call the butterfly effect
Time Boom and in a supreme Act of
selfishness shattered history like a
rank amateur and I'm the villain things
aren't looking good
[Applause]
God the sound effects too yeah the sound
Design's been solid
oh it's cold
[Music]
oh no
oh how is the enchantment broken with a
word
speak the word no shut them
I'll speak it again
will decorate my Great Hall
oh
[Music]
hero
friend
you can fix some skinny Clark
uh
there will be no glorious Victor Diana
what I do now I do for the good of all
as do I
oh boy
[Music]
what are you doing getting you out of
here
oh no it's too late huh
wow as long as I can siphon up the speed
force you can't escape this timeline I'm
afraid there just isn't enough speed
force to go around
oh
that'll do it
wow
brain full frame
Gun Man gun man doing the work gun man
doing the work his last act as Gun Man
take my gun
the world
run
go go go go go go go go go come on Barry
I was wrong
oh come no
[Music]
it's interesting too what they oh
whoa whoa
you'll kill everyone
oh wow
[Music]
who the hell
whoa
trippy
oh Jesus
hahaha
[Laughter]
great fake great fake
I think I finally got it Mom the things
you were trying to teach me
Barry Iris oh
you broke the coronal barrier went back
in time prevented your mother's murder
and completely changed the time stream
nearly destroying the entire world
so cool I remember every birthday cake
my mother ever baked me perhaps some
kind of temporal after effect or perhaps
it was a gift
oh I guess because he had it on him
[Music]
the Batman who cries
from the yellow lines now too yeah yeah
it's my favorite flash suit the balance
yeah
goberry
[Music]
yeah yeah
sweet dude that was like Phantasm good
that was really really good that was so
legit they did so much in an hour and 20
minutes because Flashpoint is dense I
was gonna say how does this stack up as
an adaptation there's only a couple
little side things they they like it's
it's the story like I'm shocked at how
like they authentically captured that
that that's the story I thought that was
Michael B Jordan yeah what a stacked
cast I was like it's definitely gonna be
his voice they really did the damn thing
yeah
so I haven't reread Flashpoint because I
was going to read it right before the
movie The live action movie and I'm glad
I didn't because now I'm gonna have I
remember the big beats and this hit all
the big beats with giving me a couple
surprises of like who killed who when
because if I just read it I'd like
remember it all but I think going into
the movie which is going to be very
different that's the way to do it well
and it's interesting too because yeah
like watching this I'm like okay I could
see what Zack Snyder used you know right
for uh especially the Snyder cut things
and even with uh Barry coming through
the speed force to talk to Bruce yes
like you know it's interesting that The
Flash movie will
Aquaman cool Danny Houston I thought
that was him Ron Perlman was Deathstroke
I love that he was Lex Lange we'll have
to pull up the cast list after this just
to have everybody yeah so grifter was
Jim Lee so I do think that was that
early 90s so grifter's cool because his
mask is literally just a piece of fabric
and it's tied behind his head so it
always like drifts so it's literally
like a grifter like a guy in the street
like it is yeah that's delightful
there's a Merc on the edge
I'm so impressed with that yeah this is
really good this is like really tight
and like such a great way to disconcert
you throughout the use of sound was
great yeah like you said the silence in
the beginning and the silence at the end
like when he went through time
really cool use of sound design really
good bookends thematically yeah and it
was so heavy like the comic is brutal I
mean this is brutal but the comic like
it's one of those books you like finish
a chapter and you're like because of the
Cliffhanger I want more but I'm so
emotionally raw take a break yeah it's
like a brutal read it's a bleak world
and it's uh I think it was who wrote
Grant Morrison and I think it was in the
Jeff John's run but I remember like the
the impact and all the other Comics was
pretty huge too oh it's got to be right
I mean this is the kind of story you do
when you're like
I love uh I was so afraid I ruined it
for you because I was like you don't
know who Bruce is I mean you know what
happened to Bruce and I was like oh no
oh did I go away too much and then then
the Joker vote and I was like oh oh dude
that was nuts what a great way to birth
The Joker that was so nuts and it's like
you know I would have watched more of
that like I would have watched scenes
with her like being the Joker but you
don't even need it it's just knowing
that that's what happened in Crime Alley
instead is like the perfect twist in the
comics they have that so you can read it
oh good uh
yes okay so does this have a direct
sequel then because I know some of the
animation movies have like a shared
Universe sequel situation is does it go
right into dark side because that'd be
dope it could it could I'm not sure
because I know that's a Thing This was
2013. oh crap that was 10 years ago they
did a great job 20 years ago oh there's
a justice league dark apocalypse war
that might be it yeah maybe uh because
etragon being introduced like that
allows for a lot anyway we'll we'll find
out what the continuity is because I am
so down audience if you want more of us
watching these you let us know if you
want that comment I'll do these all day
every day these are these are super fun
because I feel like these have the best
of both worlds like yeah like watching
under the Red Hood watching this and
just thinking about the couple other of
especially the DC animated movies I've
seen it's like they have I feel like
some of the grittiness that the
live-action movies are always trying to
capitalize on now but they have just the
right amount amount of comic book
wonderness 2. like this is super dark
but it's still like a comic book in a
way that's like totally to me
appropriate so like I love these like
these these are in some ways like ideal
iterations of these two I'd like
Flashpoint the one that's coming out to
reset the universe which I think it
inevitably is because there's no this
sounds disrespectful it's not uh with
how much they're changing without it
changing everything to reset the
Universe I don't think they'd be
fighting so hard to get it out yeah you
know what I mean like if they've moved
it up even right so like if you're gonna
cancel things like if you're gonna make
the 90 million dollar tax cut off back
Earl you would more likely make the 200
million dollar tax cut off Flashpoint
sure so like I feel like it has to reset
the universe yeah but now would be the
time and now is the time because you're
because you're resetting but what I'm
curious about is like Aquaman 2 will
come out yeah
like how does that yeah they're like are
we gonna get a bunch of like hanging
threads of is this gonna become like a
Ryan Murphy situation or like the X-Men
yeah look at what New Mutants did is
Aquaman X-Men or Shazam 2x man oh New
Mutants where it's like the kids get
moved they get delayed they get canceled
there's Cliffhangers that sets up you
know I I'm fascinated to know you know
because it would seem like yeah after a
Flashpoint movie you would have to have
a even if you kept the same casting and
part of me wonders if they may continue
with some or a lot of the casting but
yeah I think they are because they gave
Patty Jenkins the option to do Wonder
Woman three and it sounds like she's the
one that didn't like the notes right
because like the report that came out
was like hey we just want you to rewrite
this for this tone and she was like this
is the one Roman I want to do and it
seemed like it was a mutually like they
all decided not to go together so I
don't know if they'd go to Patty Jenkins
and Gal Gadot if not that yeah yeah and
that gives me some hope in Henry Cavill
but with Flashpoint the live action
movie just moved up like you said which
is a bummer because it means we don't
get that anniversary date with Batman oh
that was my first thought it was like
the the 623 was the tie-in Batman the
Keaton Batman and as you can see there's
a lot of Batman man yeah I mean because
I hear it's like a Batman 89 sequel more
as much as it's a Flash movie
yeah well I have after everything we
just heard about like the Batman Beyond
you know proposed uh movie too with the
eve going even further back into the
Burton verse yeah uh and yeah it's like
I could see how you would adapt and
change this to incorporate a Michael
Keaton Batman but if you're restarting
everything through Flashpoint you could
have Flashpoint that's we're about to
get in in the summer six months away
that could be the end of the universe
and then we could do a Flashpoint
Trilogy in 10 years that would be so I
mean like you could you could build up
to Flashpoint again with your new cast
yeah because it makes me wonder what the
flashpoint movie and we'll talk about
this movie at some point but yeah so
sorry it's just what my brain is yeah
absolutely no it makes me wonder what
the flashpoint movie is going to look
like when compared to this because it
seems like with what it needs to do
functionally for the current DCU it
would have to change a good amount of
things and probably swap out certain
care I mean like you know the the core
characters
would probably stay the same in certain
parts of the conflict but you know
there's all the difference that we've
never yeah like whoa you know what I
mean yeah yeah and then what's going to
be the involvement there is no hell
Jordan of of yeah and is there going to
be a war between Atlantis and uh
themescura is there going to be Wonder
Woman and Aquaman so I'd love for them
to do a Flashpoint that's coming out to
end the universe and then adapt this
as a trilogy yeah I mean I guess it's
good that the movie isn't called
Flashpoint right that helps you know
because yeah it's like you can do
Flashpoint things but you could probably
save the intimacies of this story you
know for later minus the the stuff where
he saves him yeah and then you can like
have the same mom conflict with the new
Flash because I I almost guarantee mom
flick mom flicked if you will because I
guarantee there's going to be a new
Flash at the end of The Flash movie
um yes Ezra Miller I mean again there's
at least three as a result of Ezra's
Miller yes so many Ezra's Miller okay so
this movie sorry I got excited because
I'm really excited for what they're
building James Gunn and Peter saffron
but this movie itself uh 10 years old
um holds up incredibly well I was so
impressed this might be like mask of the
Phantasm I consider the definitive
Batman movie I love Nolan's I love
batinson I love bat Fleck I love them
all but like they're all within the
parameters of the universe they're
building like the Batman built a new
universe
um you know Chris Nolan's Batman is a
new universe and what Ben Affleck was
able to do was in the parameters of Zack
Snyder what Phantasm was was the Batman
animated series which to me is one of
the best adaptations of the comic book
to life like that feels like the comic
book so I feel like Phantasm is the most
we can feel like we're watching a comic
come to life yeah
this was on par with that for me and
that's saying a lot like this is an a
this is solid it's incredible how much
like three different points I was like
this is moving like there's so much
happening in all the worlds yeah when it
moves and it's really tight but it
doesn't feel rushed right you know which
was is very gratifying especially you
know when you compare to some of these
movies that have you know the same
amount to do in more time yeah you know
which is funny to me and I mean granted
you know there's I I'm sure a difference
in sensibility I'm sure you can uh you
know accept things easier in an animated
setting than a live-action setting for
certain things but no totally like a
mask of the Phantasm does have that
quality where it's like this is absolute
lutely you know cut of the comic cloth
but it's still Gothic and kind of heavy
and there are you know there's Pathos
and nuances that you know are also
cinematic and like a full-on movie and
yeah this definitely has that quality
and I I loved the disconcertion of it
all and like does it play out that way
in the comment like when comic is so
uncomfortable I bet I bet because this
was uncomfortable and I loved that yeah
they throw that stuff at you of like he
sees his mom on the street and it's like
whoa whoa wait wait what what what's
what's happening right now and then not
even revealing you know Barry going back
and screwing everything up until the end
yeah really showing you that like I love
he's the villain yeah yeah and you're
sitting there this whole time being like
it's got to be reverse flash but no he's
just capitalizing on Barry's grief as
Barry goes off and you know destroys the
universe he's so nihilistic he's like
nah you you did this you brought rather
us all die you brought this to me I'm
just doing the ride I just wanted one
last fight so I could see you lose and I
love to that like
here see this is the thing it's like it
it's strengthened even
I was watching this and thinking like
okay so I can see some of the threads of
this in like what Zack Snyder does say
with Batman and and it was getting me to
that point where I'm like ah but I get
the sort of rigidity of certain fans
about Batman and guns because like I can
as much as I ideologically don't like
gun toting Batman you know if the movie
is whatever enough for my taste or
whatever I can I can handle it it's fine
but here it made me appreciate I was
like oh having Thomas Wayne become
Batman it makes a lot more sense that
this guy would be the gun using Batman
from the angle of the grief you know
through which he is seeing all this and
if Thomas Wayne uses guns and Bruce
Wayne uses guns Thomas Wayne's not
exceptional yeah and so like you can't
make a Thomas Wayne in the Snyder
Universe really yeah yeah so I was like
this it's it's the perfect contrast
because you see Batman and I love that
they that they used Batman and that's a
different voice uh casting I believe
okay
um because yeah it's like I love the
contrast and I love that yeah you you
really get to live in that when you meet
meet Thomas is Batman and I love the
reveal of that I love that they changed
the designs that you could be like wait
a minute and then it finally comes out
and you're like holy [ __ ] yeah but also
yeah the true contrast of the themes
there of him being yeah a more
nihilistic Batman but not I guess what I
loved so much about that turn finally to
get to the point is the Nuance that he's
not actually like Bizarro Batman or like
Mega Batman he's just a harsher tougher
you know his kid get murked and his wife
going yeah he's a more nihilistic Batman
his wife became the Joker like of course
this guy's gonna be the way he is but
he's not a villainous version that you
have to think that oh okay this is
reverse world so he's gonna be a villain
but you know yeah like you have him
somewhere in the middle cyborg is still
just good guy cyborg yeah and then
Wonder Woman and Aquaman are completely
off the deep end over there and then
you've got all these other figures sort
of like in limbo in between this is like
the way everybody gets recontextualized
and why they become the different people
on this timeline I thought it was just
so cool and and the experience of how
they developed and showed you that was
uh was like so fun and engaging about a
third and I I remember like mentioning
aloud like I'm so impressed how much the
arcs are paying off like they they do a
really good job we know these Heroes and
even if you're not like the most
die-hard fan they're so archetypal you
know what you expect of them they did a
really good job in so fast a fashion
going like yeah but in this universe and
you still are like I buy it that would
be the thing like Aquaman is one bad day
away from taking over the planet yeah
like the one bad day concept I love so
much it's usually in tune with Batman
but one bad day is always that like
Heroes can fall like and I love that
Wonder Woman and Aquaman you know Wonder
Woman themescara is always like men like
you guys have destroyed our planet I
love that she refers to Gaia at one
point like the daughters of Atlantis all
those things are authentic to Wonder
Woman like they did the damn thing and
they did it so quickly and so well and
the casting was so immaculate like this
movie was so good yeah I mean like all
the voices too like I really enjoyed
like I you know you sit through these
movies and you're like okay who's
everybody who's playing everybody yeah
this had the right blend too of like
okay there are a couple recognizable
voices but it's also you know not too
distracting either like yeah I'm sure
I'm sure you know certain people are
sitting there picking everybody out I
didn't hear Carrie always once I was so
impressed yeah he dropped some octaves
and got zesty yeah like it's great like
I I yeah this is like it's so weird
watching these because then you're like
wow they really should just study these
when they're making I would love this
live action yeah don't just you know
carbon copy them but I feel like it's
interesting to note like I guess who
must be the creative voices behind all
these because they do seem to really
encapsulate the vibe of the DC Universe
but also know really conscientiously how
to deliver the stories efficiently
because I I mean I've thought from the
beginning uh maybe not as Trilogy maybe
at least two movies though but I flat
from the beginning you could do a movie
about like this movie opens up with our
Justice League get into some high drinks
you've got the Rogues you can you could
have a you know a series of flash movies
give us the Rogues and then it's like oh
my God all the Rogues in one and then
you have the Justice League have to
fight them that's that's like an opening
to a movie that then devolves into uh
you know like the mystery and like
what's going on you introduce this world
and then the movie ends with like
everything going wrong like everything
and you you leave a cliffhanger like
Infinity war and then the second movie
is just the the Black Hawk Down of it
all you're fighting on this planet
you've got everything going wrong and
then the third Act is him having to
sacrifice his own mother and all those
things like that's six hours like that's
so much movie and you could spend you
could spend a good amount of time
subplotting just their relationships to
the point where AI when it finally comes
time to sever that chord you feel just
as much of that pain like that that's
one thing like here I do think that you
know it's not the point and and it's not
like any of the worse off for it but I'm
like if we we I could have spent more
time seeing a couple scenes with Barry
in his mom's relationship
yeah yeah just to see like uh just to
make it that much harder to notice his
mom die and hold himself back yeah he
has to go he has to kill his mother he
has to fool to full embrace the moment
yeah and it's and it's so harsh and it
and and even though you know the the
Serenity Prayer is you know well worn
and much used you know as well here is
it used in the book is it uh yeah okay
yeah yeah but you know hearing it it's
different aloud like I wouldn't have put
that together with uh the 12 Steps but
it totally like my brain like reading it
I don't put that there but hearing it
for some reason it does because I think
movies use it so it's an auditory Cube
yeah yeah for sure uh but like I'm just
so impressed with this yeah and and
Superman too like like that's again they
build your expectations in something
like this again the way they you know
disconcert you with these little
alternate details that starts to stack
up and then you realize the world isn't
as it should be like when they go to get
Superman too I love that where he like
doesn't really speak much because of
course yeah he's been like kept in this
Vault and I love that he didn't just
like bulk back up in the sinks he
wouldn't I thought I was what I was
waiting I was like are they gonna just
make it so like the sun he flies up he
comes back and he's yeah I would have
felt so but I love that he stays alien
and Hollow and girl like we did that to
him yeah and then he goes off and you
know has a training montage off screen
and then comes down yeah and he becomes
like a creature but like a sympathetic
creature and and it's again that and
Batman it's like Batman shows up and
it's like okay they're making the
obvious oh no it's not the obvious
choice and then Superman shows up and
it's even less the obvious choice
um it's one of my favorite elsewhere
olds period and the movie this is one of
my favorite animated movies period well
yeah because it's it's I think it's it's
got the right blend of like there's a
lot of fun nerdy [ __ ] happening but also
it's not just the bingo card of all like
I feel like in the more like we're just
gonna give you what you want it's like
okay we're gonna have evil Batman show
up and then we're gonna have evil
Superman show up and you know it's gonna
be you know uh something like
I don't know like any number of like
Bizarro or justice league dark plenty of
those yeah yeah but those exist and then
and like much like red Sun it's one
twist yeah like what I love is when it's
like tweak and then it just
ramifications yeah and it's like where
things end up it makes sense because
it's not exactly what you expect and I'm
like of course Aquaman like yeah of
course Atlantis and then mascara would
be in a conflict like this given you
know there's change and sensibilities
what a great Butterfly Effect it's a
really well thought it's possible yeah
yeah and that dice roll of like well
yeah some people are still gonna be your
allies and still going to be the same
some people are going to fall into the
middle and some people are going to be
very much not what you remember and the
animation on this like it was brutal but
I was also endeared to the characters
remind me a lot of the animatrix
actually like a lot of that style where
they they had a lot of really meticulous
while still looking expensive but not
being overwrought and good placement of
when to use like CG yeah uh animation
versus what you know appears more at
this point it's you know it's like I can
never track when things are drawn by
hand reverse is drawn on a computer but
yeah you know seeing the actual 2D style
and then where they chose to embellish
and I mean like the realization of the
speed force I really liked yeah the
silence man back to that again like the
sound design here is great yeah you
jumping a couple times was largely sound
design it was funny because I jumped a
couple times because they'd manipulate
it and whether it's my memory or they
changed it slightly from the comic book
but like when people will be taken out
like a couple times it was like aha I
gotcha and like they did such a good job
because in the comic books like the
comics are great because your
imagination is a lot of the sorrow like
you're you're experiencing it and you're
visualizing it and you're like having
those moments of the with the character
and obviously in the movie they're
they're delivering those moments to you
but a lot of times you turn the page and
be like and they do that here with a
sound like design like they're like
someone getting taken out by a laser
will be the same like yeah so well done
so so very yeah it's very cinematic
though yeah which again is like it's a
perfect Middle Ground I feel like I love
these I love these animated joints and
we got a little bit you know like Batman
is not you know I mean you know we the
the Thomas Wayne Batman we spend the
most time with but like we got a little
bit of Kevin I really enjoyed that like
as soon as I heard his voice because I
don't know which ones he did which ones
he didn't um so anytime I hear Kevin
Conroy it's always like okay I'm home
yeah we're home Chewie we're home well I
just hear that man's voice and it's yup
correct yeah and and two like you know
to come back to one of the you know top
tier one of the S tier DC animateds you
know it's it's heartwarming especially
here where you know we're now just
awaiting the suicide squad kill the
Justice League that final performance
this is my favorite modern uh DC
animated film I I know I need to see
more but like Batman mass of the
Phantasm I consider a childhood classic
I don't think I've had this good event
you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna
broaden that I think this is my favorite
uh comic book animated film of modern
time wow all stop like everything like I
had sexy League of Super Pets enjoyed it
four and a half Stars this is this is
this is a damn near a plus like this was
so so well done yeah uh like this gave
me the same feelings that Phantasm did
as a kid that when I agree watch I'm
like okay good it's as good as I thought
yeah this is a new got me like I'm so
impressed I'm so happy agreed yeah well
hell yeah dude have we left any Stones
unturned casting animation
adaptation Zeal more of this uh in the
comments let us know what other ones uh
you know we've done Red Hood uh we have
now done this Immaculate piece of
Flashpoint Glory uh let us know in the
comments one if there is a direct sequel
if that apocalypse moment led to
something directly two if there's
another favorite like what your favorite
is that you'd like to watch us uh have
us watch watch us watch next uh and
three when does Mr Miracle come in if
they're doing Dark Side where's my boy
because I don't want to know I want to
see it I want to be surprised okay so
like tell me so we can watch it
answer it do answer it would be
cryptically yeah be like I think you'd
like this movie Coy for no reason
whatsoever uh yeah I'm so impressed any
last notes no I'm yeah I'm just I'm I'm
dazzled and these all often again now
that I've seen them all but like the
truly truly good ones you know they make
you feel the wealth of possibility yeah
that all of these both animated live
action and otherwise could be and I like
that feeling especially when it comes to
DC I feel like you know this is a again
the pocket of DC that everybody kind of
unanimously sort of agrees on minus a
couple movies here and there whereas you
know I feel like people don't talk as
much about the animated Marvel movies as
they do the live-action Marvel movie as
far as DC like has such a beautiful grip
on that and then I just see stuff like
this and I'm like I hope they can bring
some of this sensibility and decision
making to their life they're about to
it's common yeah it's coming and I mean
James Gunn and Peter saffron have said
that you know they want their Universe
to connect across the media so you know
movies shows animated video games and
otherwise so I I keep hoping that in
these phases and part of why I'm very
much rooting for Marvel's you know new
slate of animated shows is like I feel
like the superhero ecosystem should have
a strong animated division Wing etc for
all these different universes I'm gonna
say something that's very bold this was
everything I wanted what if to be
yeah no it is yeah yeah because it feels
impactful and yet also as an else world
yeah it doesn't feel any less because
it's an else world yeah exactly it
doesn't feel like a light side quest
that isn't very consequential and and I
mean you know they they set themselves
and the what if you know animation's
gorgeous voice cast Immaculate like all
those things but it always felt like it
was just over here this felt as riveting
as anything live action yeah and it's
weird because this doesn't need to tell
you that it's going to be very important
and I feel like with what if they were
like It's Gonna connect it's gonna be
important and then it didn't and I hate
when people compare one to the other
negatively I'm just saying all the all
the boxes I want to check were checked
yeah and that's incredible yeah stay
golden Ponyboy that's a reference to see
Thomas Howell being Professor Zoom uh I
love this very much that is gonna do it
please leave a comment leave a like
share this with your friends do all the
things you do on the tubes of you I love
this very much I'm excited for the next
one let us know what you want that to be
see and we'll be back for more of this
GC animated goodness that I am loving
we'll see you soon have a good holiday
how are you friends wait Coy oh wait koi
yeah you want to shout out to patreon oh
I want to shout out yes shout out to
patreon shout out to patreon
and our special super sexy reject is
going to be Adelia Chamberlain because a
little crossover between the koi pond
and rejections right I know this name
very well helps me keep my Discord sane
I don't know those buttons I don't know
what those fonts mean I don't even know
how to do control anything Adelia keeps
me saying he's a pro she's so good and
like I'm barely I get in there once
twice a week and I go like oh no things
are on fire she's like gotcha guys much
love and appreciation with the Discord
fire extinguisher because frankly I
don't I I'm not gonna learn I'm at that
age I can't I've accepted that I will
never understand I'm old man's yell at
Cloud with Discord I'm like I can't
begin to learn this new tech see I'm
trying not to be that way about Tick
Tock I'm I'm better at Tick Tock than
Discord I'm not saying something because
I am that bad at both but Adelia keeps
it really is great at everything Adelia
Chamberlain making things work so uh
special Patron love out to Adelia for
keeping us all sane yeah
love you dear have a happy holiday now
do we now do we say the rap out stuff
end screen end screen
[Music]